Dan: We're on top of the Marina
Bay Sands hotel in Singapore.
It has one of the highest rates
of lightning strikes
in the world.
We're gonna be running
Image Based Auto-Trigger.
It sounds like
you're out of a job.
- ( lightning crackling )
- Go! Go! Go!
Gonna miss all the lightning.
Ah.
It was the first time
I think
where I've managed
to chill by the pool
in the day, but then...
- Yeah.
- ...been running around like
a nutter in the evening.
It was tiring.
The most relieving shoot
I think we've ever had.
'Cause there was the chance
that we flew 20 hours
across the world,
nothing happen,
and then we had to come back.
Fully down to chance.
I mean, don't know
what we would've done.
Should we just--
- Pub? Pub.
- Pub.
The moment when we realized
that the lightning was
on the other side
of the hotel was a fun one.
Pegging it
through the halls.
I hope no one was looking
through the spyholes
on the hotel doors.
Just seeing a bunch of crew
legging it through the hallways.
And what would we do?
My shorts are falling down.
Lightning is gonna be striking
on the Bay side.
Before we test out
lightning on Dan,
- What?
- We spoke to an expert
called Professor Liew.
- What?
Professor Liew,
how are you doing?
- Oh, hi, I'm great.
Dan, Dan, right?
- Yeah.
- Hello. Gavin.
- Yeah, right, yeah.
So we're trying to capture the
lighting in super slow motion
because when you look
at it with your eyes
it just seems instant.
How fast does lightning
actually move?
It'll be a real challenge
for you
because you know the speed
is actually very, very high.
There are two phases
to the development
of a lightning strike.
It starts from the cloud.
A lightning leader
will descend.
The speed up there is about one
tenth the velocity of light.
Now that is not the main
lightning channel.
The main lightning channel
actually develops
after contact
from the down coming leader
with the ground and then
there is this return stroke.
Which moves up from the ground
to the cloud.
And the speed of propagation
of that particular channel
is even faster.
That travels at one third
the velocity of light.
( lightning crackling )
Okay, so we got a struggle
to capture this.
Yeah, we really are.
How many volts
in a lightning bolt?
Voltage varies
from about 10 million
to 100 million volts.
- 100 million volts.
- That's a lot of voltage.
- Yeah. So--
- You could fry an egg.
I think probably.
So, I'm not planning on it,
but what's it like
to get hit by lightning?
Wow.
( laughs )
I do not advise you
to, you know,
stand out in the open
and say, "I'm invincible."
You know, try to attract
a lightning strike.
When the voltage impinges
on a person
that will cause
a current flow to the body
the amount of current
which flows depends
on the resistance
of the body.
But, you know,
in reality, you know,
when the lightning stroke
hits you directly, you know,
the chances of survival
is extremely slim.
The temperature
of a lightning channel
is about 30,000 degrees
Kelvin or centigrade.
- 30,000--
- 30,000.
And how long is it
30,000?
Just for like a split second?
It is actually, you know,
the whole duration
of the wave--
the lightning wave varies
from microseconds
to milliseconds.
You know, the duration maximum
may be about one second.
It could be fatal.
- Yeah.
- So you'd know about it
for sure.
What is the correct
thing to do
if you're out
in an open area
and there's a big lightning
storm coming in?
- Well, you try your best
to get indoors.
- Okay.
- Just run inside.
- Run inside.
He who plays
and runs away
and lives to play
another day, you know.
- ( both laugh )
- I like that.
Yeah, so, run indoors.
I think that's the most
sensible advice.
- That's stupid.
- Oh, come on.
Go, go, ask him.
So is it true, um,
you get superpowers
when you're struck
by lightning?
I wish that could
be so, you know,
then I'll become Thor
or Iron Man.
- Okay.
- No.
- The answer is no.
Oh, you mislead me
for a second.
I was like,
"Does he or what?"
- Okay, well thanks very much,
Professor.
- Okay.
- Thank you, Dan.
- Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
- Yeah.
Okay, back to you,
Gav and Dan.
Thanks, us.
- I bloody loved him.
- He was a legend.
- He reminded me of my granddad.
- Yeah.
Time for a bit
of analysis.
I wanna take one
of our clips,
find where we can see
the entire bolt
from cloud all the way
to the ocean
and time how long it took
for all the feelers
to hit the ocean
- in real time.
- I think it'll be fast.
I also think
it will be fast.
Time code is set to zero
point zero seconds.
- Yep.
- Ready to time it?
Okay. Yes.
- Uh, that was it. So--
- ( laughs ) What?
If I go frame by frame
Here we go, yeah.
- What?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So one frame is traveling
that far?
Point zero zero
zero six seconds.
- Like I said, it's fast.
- 632--
- It's so-- So, yeah.
- Really fast.
What is interesting to me,
if you look at all
these step leaders,
which is you know each finger
of the thing.
They're all trying to find
the path of least resistance
down to the planet,
but the one
that gets there first
is the one
that sends the bolt up.
But you can already
see before it wins,
what the shape
of the lightning bolt will be.
So when this hits
the ground here.
The lightning will come up
and follow the exact path
that this one took.
- So that's the exact--
- And everything else
disappears.
See, that's like the
exact perfect angle.
It's a lot going on
in just a lightning storm.
It is. It happens
so quickly as well.
There's actually a clip I found
where it's sort of
halfway coming up.
So, you mean to say that even
though the speed of lightning
of it going back up,
you managed to capture it
where it hadn't gone all the way
up yet and it was literally
only halfway up.
- Yeah, you wanna see it?
- Yeah.
- See, look at that.
- Whoa!
So that is sort of halfway
between the white out
that we saw on the other one
but it hasn't reached
this point.
So you can actually imagine
it's not actually like this.
It's just so bright,
it's blowing out the camera
from that point.
And the thing is because
of the camera that we used,
the 2512, has a global shutter.
That means this is an actual
moment in time.
This isn't an artifact
because of a rolling shutter.
This is actually
how far up it got.
So if we'd have given it enough
of tiny, tiny split second,
it would've been all the way
to the top?
Yeah. Well, because
in one 28,500th of a second,
it hit the ground and went
all the way up to here.
Shall we do a lovely
tabletop experiment?
Yeah.
You've forgotten
what it was, didn't you?
That's good,
that's good.
The Van de Graaff generator.
- Classic school experiment.
- Yep.
I like the gloves more
than anything.
Rubber gloves.
How's it work?
The way this works is similar
to lightning
in that a lot
of brushes in here
build up a static charge.
Like friction
and build up a charge.
The lighter positively charged
particles come to the top.
With lightning what happens
instead of brushes,
you get the warmer air going
to the top and then cooling
creating ice particles
that then come down
and they bash into each other
and create a static charge.
So instead of brushes
you've got ice,
and in the top of the cloud
you got the lighter particles
and the bottom is the negative.
That explains why Singapore
is such a hot spot.
It's because
of the warm climate.
- Yeah, so the water--
- Warm water, warm air.
All goes to the top, through
the clouds, forms the clouds,
ice in the top,
brushes together,
makes lightning.
- So this is ready to go.
- Yeah.
We're gonna film it
with the 2511,
very similar camera
to what we used in Singapore.
We will have
to dim the lights
because these flicker
like crazy.
And also we wanna see the spark,
not these lights.
That sounds good.
I'm kinda scared,
but also excited.
- Let's turn on the loud beast.
- Okay.
I feel like generic bad guy
from famous movie.
Yeah, yeah. All right,
so I'm gonna turn it on
and power up, okay.
- So should we turn
the lights off?
- Yeah.
Oh, you can hear it.
Okay, I'm gonna just slowly
move this closer and closer.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
Here we go.
- Oh.
- All right, stop.
Turn it off.
All right, you ready?
Playback of slow-motion footage.
- Yep.
- That's it.
That is one frame.
- One frame?
- Well, it's 28,000 frames
a second
over an inch?
I guess, uh,
because lightning is so much
further away,
it's like miles high that we are
getting much more of chance
- to see it.
- Yeah.
So I feel like this video has
been a lot of step leaders
leading down
to one main point.
Yeah.
Which is you getting zapped
by electricity.
I mean, blokes get hit
by real lightning and survive.
So what's this little thing
brushes and stuff
really gonna do?
395,000 volts.
- Is it?
- Yeah.
But think about it
like this.
( laughs )
Lightning is
a 100 million volts.
Okay, well, that makes me feel
better then.
- Are you ready?
- I guess.
All right let's get the lights
in high-speed mode.
Okay.
Here we go.
- ( groans )
- Was that it?
- Yeah, just--
- Oh, I didn't trigger.
( laughs )
I was waiting for you.
- All right, let's just
do it again.
- All right.
- ( groans )
- ( laughs )
I was not expecting that.
I think you'd have to shoot in
really close.
Oh, you just wanna go like--
( groans )
- ( laughs )
- What was I expecting?
At least let me be filming.
- All right.
- All right, you ready?
- I mean, yeah.
All right.
I'm just gonna go like--
( groans )
( bleep )!
( laughs )
Ready?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- ( groans )
- Is that it?
I guess.
I can't see. Ow!
I can't see.
Stay away
from this thing.
Why haven't I learned
my lesson here?
I keep pointing at it.
What do I expect?
- Moron.
- All right, so far
I've not seen a single spark
on this.
Really?
'Cause a finger
isn't enough of a point.
All right, I'll try it
with an elbow I guess.
Rolling.
Oh, I can feel it.
- My hair is like going
towards it.
- Yeah.
( groans )
Bloody saw that one.
That was a bright one,
wasn't it,?
- That was amazing.
- Christ.
- All right, Dan, very
good job, obviously.
- Thank you. Yeah.
- You ready for your moment
of glory?
- Can't wait.
And when I say moment
I mean a very--
it's a tiny fraction
of a second.
- Oh, there it was.
- That was it?
That was one frame.
There it is.
Also, know the fact
that it hits the ball
and then you see
the reflection...
- Oh.
- ...in the ball
back to your mirrored elbow.
That's so weird.
Imagine if it was
a lot longer
and two inches thick.
- That's what lightning's like,
ain't it?
- Yeah.
- Your arm would be gone.
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah, it'd be gone.
- You would be gone. You'd pop.
Yeah, that was fun.
Feeling all right, Dan?
- A bit tingly.
- Little bit tingly.
- Yeah, my arm's a bit numb.
- You look good.
I think we broke
the monitor, too.
- There's lightning happening
on that.
- Yes.
Like it's been affected
or something.
Everything's a bit "ooh" here.
So I feel like I learned a lot
from that episode.
I-- The main thing
I took away from that
is that essentially
all that lightning is
is a giant ball of static.
It's just huge.
On a massive scale.
It's like the biggest pair
of socks on the world's carpet.
- Yes.
- Hopefully, you enjoyed
that video.
Feel free to check out other
less shocking episodes
of "Planet Slow Mo"
and we'll just be right here
while you click
something over there.
I feel like you should get
shocked as well for this.
That's probably fair.
( zapping )